[Musique]
je voudrais savoir si vous avez de
l'argent de poche sur vous
l'argent de poche j'ai un âge où
l'argent de poche on en a forcément vous
êtes mariés oui bien sûr les deux femmes
voulaient savoir d'argent de poche
surnom quasi virtuel crise pour tout le
monde qu'est-ce qui décide à la maison
parce que moi-même petit budget mais moi
c'est vous depuis toujours c'est moi
entièrement entièrement oui s'il veut
s'acheter une robe qu'est ce qu'on fait
bah elle l'achète
elle vous demande la permission non
alors c'était le tout d'ici non fondées
si tous les deux fait ce qu'elle veut
c'est moi que j'ai décidé de racheter
mais c'est pas elle parce que l'agencé
ils sont toujours sur moi sur ma faim et
vous êtes marié aujourd'hui comme à
rennes
et si vous étiez marié qu'est-ce qui
déciderai quand je crois sincèrement non
ça dépend une partie par la fable une
partie par l'homme
c'est à dire la nourriture rien oui la
nourriture ce qui concerne la maison il
reste l'homme qui est-ce qui décide du
budget familial à la maison tous les
deux tous les deux vous n'êtes pas
toujours d'accord
pratiquement oui toujours quand votre
femme de s'acheter une robe l'achète et
quand il put sous un linge est pas fait
comme il veut je la laisse libres les
trois enfants n'a pas voulu acheter des
euros paiement mais je crois mon pdg
dans votre famille non elle
l'enfant au fur et à mesure et quant à
la bombe
le problème le sport est ce que vous
avez de l'argent de poche surtout bien
certainement oui oui oui vous êtes
mariés oui et votre femme vous laisse de
l'argent de vache mais naturellement
nous gagnons l'année l'autre au plus
exactement nous sommes à la retraite
l'un et l'autre vous avez de l'argent de
poche un petit peu oui beaucoup aux gens
une vingtaine de villes quoi vous êtes
marié et votre femme vous laisse en
argent de poche fric et les gentils pas
bien ce qu'est ce qu'ils décident du
budget à la maison
danser ma femme a deux foyers que c'est
possible
pourquoi séance encore bien donc une
raison en commun un peu avoue aussi
qu'elle travaille c'est vous de votre
rien c'est vous et vous donner de
l'argent tous les combien tous les mois
tous les samedis matins mon argent de
poche pour la semaine et qui travaille
qui fausse et c'est moi qui travaille et
vous donnez votre argent tous les mois
attendez moi demeure oui ah oui alors là
faut jamais chez moi je n'ai pas
d'histoire vous lui donnez tout tout
exactement
et qu'est ce qui va vous restez akbou
approche que rien pour les cigarettes et
va justement c'est elle qui décide tout
juste avant il faut calmer dans le
déchet pour manger dit
heureusement qu'elle travaille parce que
sinon c'est ce qu'elle a fait à ma femme
s'occupe de son employé moi de mon
travail et elle peut elle fait ce
qu'elle redoute à nous le demande à vous
allez vous marier ce possible qui est ce
qu'il a décidé du budget familial
moi je pense à vous sans doute vous
allez travailler pas et je m'en viens et
vous allez lui donnez tous votre argent
on va
on va s'arranger pour tous soit ça
partager enfin je pense que tu gagnes
quand elles voudront s'acheter une robe
il faudra qu'elle vous demande la
permission je pense donner une certaine
autonomie c'est pour moi et pour
l'appartement par exemple en revanche on
occupe au personnellement qu'est ce
qu'ils décident à la maison les grandes
dépenses pour personne il a mille autres
où tout l'élan chalon plus tôt s'il veut
s'acheter une robe qu'une femme sont
inégaux et pour vous acheter ce beau
manteau que vous portez il a fallu
demander la permission à non parce que
ça c'est très bien que j'aime bien c'est
pratique ça va pour la pluie soleil
elle a été d'accord et les pélicans et
n'est pas d'accord quand nous allons
je sors avec son manteau la chaux des
amis très tôt que fait-on campagnard et
que tu as de l'argent de poche sur toi
non non
qui est-ce qui a l'argent à la maison
c'est ton papa ou la maman et les gars à
qui on demande du haut uélé soit ma mère
mon père bob pas ces moments tout
dimanche j'ai l'argent de poche aussi
oui et qu'est ce qui donne l'argent chez
toi à mes parents et à maman le demande
à tampa bay quelques fois oui il le
donne gentiment oui qu'est-ce qui te les
donne c'est un saut ce numéro les
courses a pour elle le prend sur
l'argent des coops a mûri
ah bon et elle demande l'argent des
courses à ton papa
oh oui ça lui arrive et ils le donnent
toujours on se presse que tu genre
[Musique]